uh he's at an airport with a cat okay
that that sounds Wow
you know I better check on him big
season finale right there you know
better uh better go right now also I
told you not to get a dragon Morty this
is your fault
you worst adventurous adventure ever
welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is gonna be my Rick
and Morty season 4 episode 4 video does
anybody know how long it takes a dragon
to fly to Florida there were a whole
bunch of Easter eggs well break it all
down if you're new to the channel I'm
doing videos for all the episodes this
season be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's also a new merch
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the episode on the
video careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet we'll start
with top 10 WTF and Easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 10 the title
of the episode claw and hoarder special
ricktum morty a reference to Law & Order
Special Victims Unit
if you don't remember that's the TV show
that ice-t has been on for a billion
years he was also the subject of water
tea during get schwifty apparently now
he's actually a really big fan of Rick
and Morty so maybe he'll come back and
guest stars a different character at
some point but the episode itself was
mostly a parody of Dungeons & Dragons
and pretty much every dragon trope
you've ever heard of from every dragon
TV show or movie but number 9 r.i.p
chachi in the cold open they do the same
type of cold open bit that they did
during season 3 episode 6 where they go
on this adventure that seems like it's
supposed to be this really quick thing
but morty implies has been in this alien
prison for a long time so apparently
this adventure has gone on much longer
than what it seems like at the beginning
of the episode rick sends morty on a
mission to get an ultimate cube he gets
captured thrown in alien prison
chachi helps him escape they imply that
they have all this history that they
developed over the course of this
adventure and then he just gets gunned
down immediately
and they use it as a way to show you how
self-centered rick is that he would put
Morty through something like this and
then totally not care about chachi and
once morty produces the ultimate cube
rick just immediately doesn't care about
it because it's purple like the one that
he already has they also used the
cold-open to show you morty being more
assertive recognized how much rick is
being a dick demanding that he get his
dragon it's just part of the general
progression of the Morty character
slowly and slowly becoming more sort of
ensure of himself
the funny thing about that though they
pay it off at the end of the episode is
that even though he is becoming more
assertive in sure of himself his ideas
aren't getting better
worst adventure ever Morty
they all run off in different directions
even though we learned this in last
week's episode Rick reminds us that he's
familiar with Marvel Comics because he
offered to give him Wolverine claws
during last week's episode he made the
Doctor Strange joke ripoff dr. strange
so he has seen the Marvel movies the bit
about nerds refusing to admit that
they're Christian being into dragons I
think is mostly a general dig at the
paradox of being a nerd who's into
fantasy but also science fiction to
genres that are typically in opposition
to each other in the way they explain
how things work bringing it back around
to the Doctor Strange movie that movie
attempted to explain magic in a
scientific way and Dan Harmon consulted
on the Doctor Strange movie punching up
their script in some places to help them
explain some really complicated scenes
in really simple ways they says it's the
reason why he was brought onto the dr.
strange movie is because of the Rick and
Morty stuff because the Marvel people
that make those movies like Rick and
Morty because they're able to explain
very complicated concepts in very simple
ways the whole bit with Rick
accidentally gassing himself while
trying to get Morty to shut up and then
just landing himself in the hospital
with all those injuries it's just a poor
salt on the wound reminding you that
he's no longer head of the family like
he was during season 3 where Beth walks
in and says did you actually promise
more do you dragon yeah you have to live
up to that promise
number 8 Morty gets his dragon Dan
Harmon is voicing the wizard who
controls all the dragons and executes
the soul bond contract with Morty the
soul bond itself is a combination of
references and easter eggs for a bunch
of different dragon based movies and TV
shows like when Rick is shown being hurt
because the wizard is hurting the dragon
or when summer shoots the dragon in the
eye that's a reference to the movie
dragon heart with Sean Connery the
dragon in that movie gives a human half
of its heart linking them so when you
hurt one you heard the other but the
soul bond is a reference to dragon
bonding something that shows up in a
bunch of different TV shows and movies
the very overt sexual jokes that they
laid on top of this though made me think
more of the Anne McCaffrey dragonriders
of Pern series if you've never read that
there's this intense psychic bond
between dragons and their riders that
forms and when two dragons go into heat
so to speak and start mating the psychic
feedback loop that it causes with their
riders forces the riders of the
different dragons that are mating to
make themselves sometimes involuntarily
like more
didn't have anything to do with their
creepy group soul bond session but he
has to anyway
just another thing that Rick will
probably have to erase from his mind
Jerry's mind blowers too got a big
callback at the end of the episode but
if you watched Game of Thrones you also
know the dragon bonding is something
that's common to that series of people
of Valyrian descent like the Targaryen
family but it's not quite as intense
during the Song of Ice and Fire series
as it is drained the Anne McCaffrey book
series a lot of all these magic tropes
and jokes reminded me of Dan Harmon's
Harmon quest which is also his ongoing
Dungeons & Dragons role-playing game
that he turned into a web show we also
meet Bal from our the dragon played by
Liam Cunningham from Game of Thrones
sur Davos himself finally playing a
dragon they keep referring to the
Dragons like cats and then there's the
separate talking cat in the episode the
noises that the Game of Thrones dragons
made were modeled after at large cat
animals that purr but number 7 Jerry's
talking cat you may have recognized that
the talking cat that Jerry goes to
Florida with is voiced by Matthew
Broderick himself but the cat itself was
mostly their B's story in this in that
he was created to be this metaphor for
the voice inside the writers heads in
real-life overthinking problems so
that's why the cat kept telling Jerry
not to overthink things it was the
writers speaking to themself in a meta
way through the script because of the
way they ended that story too it also
may have been a reference to the parody
cartoon dark version of Garfield about
the cat that stalks its owner called I
am sorry Jon number 6 Rick wants to slay
the dragon he breaks the fourth wall
when he says that this is the end of the
Morty gets a dragon episode because he
knows that they're inside a fictional TV
show but the TV show within the TV show
that Rick and summer are watching and
making fun of called ass is just a
parody of bones in real life the story
of the ass show and everything that they
say about it the characters is basically
directly ripped off of the bones TV show
in real life with the two characters
getting together oh it's boring no I
don't want to watch it anymore Rick then
references drag-race when he says I
always slay Queen in number five Rick
versus the dragon and his giant treasure
hoard of Easter eggs Rick goes down and
makes fun of all kinds of dragon tropes
oh if only I wouldn't have planned for
the only thing the Dragons are known for
breathing fire usually every time an
episode is based on a lot of really
overt trophy
things he starts calling them out in an
episode he spent the entire episode
making fun of magic when you look at all
the treasures that he has in the
background there's the venus de milo
statue i'm assuming it's an original
because he has so much unique stuff in
that hoard he also has what looks like a
tesla car or some kind of sports car a
classic Ghostbusters hi-c ecto cooler
which I myself actually drank a ton of
as a little kid he's also got an Action
Comics number one the first appearance
of Superman a Dan Harmon Funko pop a
classic duck man animated series
lunchbox small soldiers spin pops would
say directly call out and then future
self-titled album on vinyl signed in
Molly and percocet there's a bunch of
other stuff in the background that they
don't really spend a lot of time on or
is cut off in frame so if you spotted
any other Easter eggs in the Dragons
treasure hoard just write them below in
the comments but then number four
rigging the dragon party turns out
dragons really like to party in their
super polyamorous they partake in
volcanic fumes which may or may not mess
with Rick's higher brain function who
cares he doesn't mind they played the
song from the album that they just
referenced when they're flying around
just getting wasted together they make
fun a Taylor Swift when they ignore
Morty's call sending him the gift of her
pumping her fists summer explains that
that means you're lame Morty the speech
that the dragon then gives to rick is
actually meant to be true meant to be
taken seriously
there will be sayings about you your
lessers will hunt you down and you are
one of a dying breed literally because
Rick's get killed all the time but also
evil Morty is probably going to come for
c-137 Rick eventually because the
episode is all about bad relationships
toxic relationships they execute their
soul bond
Morty watches them Rick gets really
weird about it then the wizard comes
back and starts slut-shaming the dragon
so number three Rick Morty and summer go
to rescue the dragon from the wizard
Rick gets really pissed off because the
laws of physics are completely whack and
magic is the only thing that works in
this realm science won't help him we
learn it takes 78 years to actually hang
a dragon they get kind of steampunky
with the weapon that Rick picks up but
the weapon itself works a lot like the
impossibility drive from Hitchhiker's
Guide turning things into random objects
when he shoots them Rick continues to
make fun of magic because it seemingly
has no rules why be worried about
anything when it doesn't make any sense
summer even tries to shoot an arrow
of her but before she accidentally hurts
Rick by shooting the dragon in the eye
when the wizard stomps out - if you look
in the background you can kind of see
him like he's been skyping with some
scantily clad sorceress in the
background we meet the other [ __ ]
dragons some of which are so weird and
creepy that the other regular [ __ ]
dragons don't want to have anything to
do with them if they all wind up in a
creepy group soul bond with the
creepiest oldest grossest dragon called
shadow chucker he seems like something
out of the bowels of some creepy tumblr
fan fiction in his staff that he carries
around which Rick doesn't notice right
away oh I just saw what the staff is but
they forced themselves into that group
soul bond they defeat the wizard is
actually some beautiful animation even
though when you think about what's
actually happening in this scene it's
kind of gross they defeat the wizard who
somehow makes his suffering worse by
freezing himself before the dragon
roasts him alive just more harmontown
harm and quest jokes Rick makes fun of
the Wizards magical portals because who
writes on portals and then things get
super awkward when Liam Cunningham's
dragon follows them home hoping to
continue their weird toxic relationship
first with Rick who then leaves to help
Jerry which tells you how badly Rick
wants out of this situation then Morty
who just repeatedly has to tell him to
leave because the dragon starts to
embarrass himself Rick also breaks the
fourth wall again when he says that
there's a real big season finale
situation with Jerry that he has to help
out with then blame everything that
happened in this episode on Morty
because he's the one that wanted a
dragon so bad but number two WTF Jerry's
mind blowers rico's to pick up Jerry the
airport with a talking cat they find out
why the cat can talk it turns out is so
horrific that Rick has to erase Jerry's
mind you're not really meant to
understand why the cat can talk remember
the whole point of the cat storyline is
this the writers not overthinking things
sometimes something weird happens in an
episode for strange reasons and is not
meant to make a lot of sense in number
one WTF the post-credits scene with a
dragon homeless dragging his treasure
hoard down the street the random dude
tries to pick him up for money until the
talking cat matthew broderick comes back
to start a relationship with it and get
him to fly him back to Florida how long
does it take a dragon to fly to Florida
let me know in the comments if you
spotted any big easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't mention in the
video like i said big dungeons and
dragons episode of Rick and Morty
overall I liked it a little bit better
than last week's episode but it was way
way grosser there'll be a new crisis on
Infinite Earths episode tonight Tom
Welling from Smallville is gonna be
cameo in along with Kevin Conroy Batman
from Batman the Animated Series there's
a whole bunch of other stuff so as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see all the videos when I
post them but click here to rewatch the
Wonder Woman 1984 trailer a billion more
times and click here for my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 3 video thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]